by reading the required statement
as chair judiciary committee i find that
due to the state of
emergency declare winner as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
and evidence with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on